Ohio congressman Tim Ryan has dropped
out of the presidential race yeah in a
related story Ohio congressman Tim Ryan
was apparently in the presidential race
I had no idea did you I had no idea how
I every day I'm like well Gus Williams
is out I'm like who's Koloff Johnson
dropped out Wow
what else is going on today Vice
President Mike Pence ripped into the MBA
for acting like a subsidiary of China
yeah
spokesperson spokesperson for the league
said China is nothing like the NBA they
have a one-child policy this guy this
guy is shot he's covering his face he's
so shocked he wasn't aware that the NBA
is very prolific yeah that was that one
with a crowd was like yeah that's right
behind that one speaking of presidential
candidates presidential candidates are
raising huge amounts of money for their
campaigns Bernie Sanders did you hear
this has raised 61 million dollars this
year while President Trump and the RNC
combined to raise a staggering 125
million dollars in just three months yes
fortunes these candidates are raising
big big money except for one I'm talking
about Wayne Messam then yes this is real
I wasn't kidding when I said there are
people running and you didn't know Wayne
Messam the mayor of Miramar Florida
who's running for president his campaign
this is absolutely real I am NOT making
this up raised a total last quarter of
$5
five dollars I was curious how can you
only raise five dollars so I looked into
it I think I figured out the reason take
a look at this video from Wayne mesons
campaign website this presidential
election it may seem like you have many
choices but they're all saying the same
darn thing except one
Wayne Messam join our movement by
donating online it's simple just go to
WWE - M - E - s - s underscore a n not
m.com from there you'll find our link to
donate this will take you to our
campaign donation portal because of a
misunderstanding with our web hosting
service our donation portal is shared
with a recruitment site for Isis so
please make sure to donate to Wayne
messes campaign and not the radical
Islamic terrorist group by clicking the
join our movement arrow beneath Isis's
side of the page but pointing to our
side of the page easy right okay and
then from there simply fill out your
personal information and primary vehicle
VIN number got it great now you're ready
to begin the Wayne mesm campaign accepts
payments exclusively through a crypto
currency called finga simply download
the fing Go app available exclusively
for the palm OS once you've synced bingo
to your browser you gotta catch the
donate button
got it now you just have to complete the
CAPTCHA and the reCAPTCHA then draw
spider-man then take your drawing a DNA
sample and an unused postal stamp and
mail them to our campaign headquarters
in four to six days you'll receive a
unique authentication key in the mail
good for two hours nonsense
just enter the key correctly but
backwards and your generous donation
will be on its way thanks for supporting
Wayne Messam who just dropped out of the
presidential race
you